the hot hot post offense your Center has
to be that a good passer to fine
all away
that's that give me that contest me one
of the most improved big guys in the
country
Xavier Simpson will inbound the ball
from Michigan again this game is tied at
two somebody went to snoop went
underneath the two that's what happened
when you try to cheat over the pig 12
Player of the Year he'll drive he'll
take it on slithering for two he's got
length size can handle the basketball
second consecutive season nice job
defensively by Francis shot clock at
five a few struggles and finds the toots
momentarily by Matthews now the shot
clock is at three many spins fires
[Applause]
and transferred from the University of
South Dakota nephew spinning [ __ ]
tasty inside with a plush there's the
switch you're talking about I know
minute first half defense with high
strips by both teams were ready off the
glass sat on the cloud da the name
already he's got seven
with a nice moon actually what they got
Moretti
it's moody Maroni teased what a path and
that is an actual dream that you give to
the Israelis and this is very
interesting you draw the defense and
then you kick it out to Moretti now he
is a really good three-point shooter who
has not shot the three wells so far that
17 minutes left
[Applause]
first of all they went up high and Owens
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
on a double figures from Michigan its
Simpson shed one defender Blazers one
inside prawns tickets got hammered ball
is loose and picked up my company that
was always with the block side he said
he let the Big East while you with that
[Applause]
[Music]
matchup zone other Red Raiders for $200
everything though is a struggle on vista
flee for Michigan that Muniz got the
ball up high
they sneak it into reverse and he pulls
up
look at this quick move here by Coleman
couple yellow jerseys come over just a
little too highly rated individual
player as there is the game and in this
tournament practice haka boom and a foul
comet for two with eight in minutes and
change to play I will look at you crazy
as Davis so they can add the entire
group back at Michigan will try just
spectacular rotation over here by Tariq
this is that's special well again they
try to force you out of the middle down
the side of the leg on March Madness
live bared three and he got it to go in
did over his other shop that he made
this year was a three that was it in
Snow Crash go
and that'll go and Texas Tech won't for
a second consecutive year be a part of
it